ted thank you for that well a really a
really unique project is underway in the
valley of fire the nevada department of
wildlife is teaming up with the utah
division of wildlife resources to create
the first bighorn sheep nursery in utah
and that means it's moving day for some
bighorn sheep in the valley of fire
photojournalist henry takai takes us out
there
in the valley of fire state park they've
graciously let us utilize their group
use area and we captured 16 sheep
yesterday and the goal is to send 14
more today and these sheep are going to
utah as part of a new nursery group
concept
brainerd keeper cool we got cool towels
on it we've got hotels around our horn
this is actually the first year we're
attempting a summer net gun capture and
it's worked very well the animal
temperatures have been really low
we've only had to apply two ivs you
taking blood samples when we get an
animal in the most important thing we're
looking at is temperatures so we're in
the middle of june temperatures are warm
we're keeping chase time short when they
go up and capture the sheep utah is
starting a new healthy herd so while
this herd has never had mycoplasma which
is the cause of a agent of bighorn
pneumonia we want to make sure they're
still negative and we're not giving them
any sheep
that would have that disease by removing
animals off the landscape here we're
reducing competition for the other
animals that are going to persist
through the summer months
take support from multiple agencies
multiple ngo groups to make this happen
we are still in a prolonged drought
condition and that's one of the main
reasons why we're conducting this
capture just a few years ago the
population estimate in unit 268 or the
muddy mountains was about 750 animals
and now it's about 550.